joe rogan
in conversation with comedian dave smith
uh said something offhandedly about
advice that he would give
to a young person
considering whether or not to get
vaccinated for
covid actually maybe zach we should show
that clip
yeah i think for the most part it's safe
to get vaccinated i do
i do but if you're like 21 years old and
you say to me should i get vaccinated i
go no
yeah are you healthy are you a healthy
person
like look don't do anything stupid but
you should take care of yourself
you should if you're if you're a healthy
person and you're exercising all the
time when you're young
and you're eating well and like i don't
think you need to worry about this
now rogan was careful not to say that
all people shouldn't be vaccinated okay
so um that was joe rogan and what he
said
is that if he was advising a healthy
person something like 21 years of age
that he would likely advise them not to
get the vaccine
and the world jumped on joe and of
course
mocked him and made fun of him for not
having the expertise
to say such things and my sense
was although i didn't think joe gave a
complete analysis here
of why what he suggested might make
sense i actually didn't think that the
advice he was giving was so terrible
because
of course there are all sorts of
questions that do suggest we should at
least be thinking twice about advising
young people
to get the vaccine so in other words
well
what we had was we had uh fouchy
weighing in
and saying that of course young people
should get the vaccine and then
fauci although i don't think joe was
wrong fauci said some things that were
true
what he said was that joe's analysis
seemed to pay attention only to one's
personal
well-being and that he was not paying
proper attention to the fact
that a healthy person who gets coveted
and suffers from it only very little
may be exposing other people to the
virus and they may suffer greatly and in
fact could could die from it and that
that is a reason to get the vaccine and
in isolation uh that uh
analysis is probably right but that
analysis does not exist
in isolation and so i wanted to
take some time to sort through the
various things that contribute to the
analysis of
who should get vaccinated but you had a
point yeah i mean there are many points
to be made here and i know we're going
to spend some time talking about this
but
um just to finish up your sort of
reporting of what it is that you're
responding to here
uh joe did uh clarify with an additional
statement after
fauci um said what he said and it's too
long i think
to play here it's you know five seven
minute um thing but uh he made he
he exactly um repeated the point that
you just made which is this is an
individual enamel
individual level analysis not a
population level analysis and he was not
presuming to make the population level
analysis those aren't his words
no i saw the retraction or the walking
back it wasn't really a retraction but
in any case i was a little bit concerned
about it because my sense is
you know joe is a layperson
he was having a discussion that did not
pretend to be
uh authoritative in this regard and so
it was incomplete but it wasn't
pretending to be a complete
analysis and um the fact is i thought
joe was on much stronger ground
in light of what we've been talking
about on dark horse for
so many months now which is the huge
unknowns that surround vaccine safety
long term and so the analysis about
whether or not a young person
should get vaccinated should center
on some kind of balance between yes the
possibility that a young person could
get
coveted could pass it on to other people
but also the possibility that
a young person could get a vaccine and
then suffer
hazards down the road and that analysis
does not suggest that this is clear-cut
in fouchy's direction
um that is my water kitty cat um that
this is clear-cut in in fouti's
direction and against joe
so i thought uh you know i mean i
certainly understood that
joe was in a bad position um that in
effect somebody
you know without a credential was
vulnerable to the world piling on that
he was giving medical advice that he
wasn't in a position to give
but he wasn't pretending to be a medical
authority um so
before we start walking through some of
some of what we do
see with regard to the data um
the wapo the washington post joined the
fray with
this piece you can show my screen just
for me to read the headline zack
joe rogan is using his wildly popular
podcast to question vaccines
experts are fighting back so that's you
know one of one of the main
news outlets in the united states
here and i'm just gonna read from my
screen zach so you don't have to show
um show it again um two paragraphs near
the end
of this wapo article dated april 29th
this is two days ago
misinformation coming from someone like
rogan continues to perpetuate doubt said
kalina koltai a vaccine misinformation
researcher at the university of
washington
a lot of young adults follow him and
he's encouraging people to have
hesitation
coltai pointed out that quote no one is
getting all of their information from
joe rogan
but when his comments clash with what
experts tell us it helps muddy the
waters
quote hearing these conflicting messages
from someone you might trust and someone
you might agree with typically
it can potentially cause you to be
concerned she said quote
oftentimes it just ends up confusing
people and making them not sure what to
do
so that language struck me as so
anti-scientific
and um like just antithetical to
skepticism
that although i don't tend to do this
certainly not on
air i just i went and figured out who
this person was who was being trotted
out as the expert
who is saying that uh that rogan doesn't
know what he's doing
um she is a postdoc at uw at university
of washington
with a phd in quote information studies
she's not a scientist
and she states on the website um the
university website that she researches
quote
decision making with a focus on when
people dissent from the scientific
mainstream
that has nothing to do with science and
that actually may exactly be
training that she has that that allows
her to speak as if expert here
that runs exactly opposed to what the
scientific method is she may well know
what information is
and and what it looks like when people
start to disbelieve
things that most people believe to be
true but disbelieving what most people
believe to be true does not mean
that those people are themselves wrong i
don't think that she i i see nothing and
i spent just a little bit of time with
her website
um indicating that she actually
understands what the scientific method
is
and i'm not saying that you know if i
put her and joe rogan in a room
and ask them to find the scientific
method that one of them would obviously
come out on top but i feel like
joe is personifying on a regular basis
a skeptical approach to the world in
which he is using
largely his intuition rather than formal
training
to try to navigate and he is not
accepting the basis of
authority and you know we are being told
in response
how dare you listen to this man you must
trust the authorities and the
authorities are
over and over and over again
demonstrating that they actually don't
even know what science is
right in fact the entire idea of
taking science and marshaling against
those who would challenge it is the
height of
unscientific right everything we now
believe
started out as a heterodoxy right and it
comes to be orthodoxy because it
withstands tests and we find out how it
works
but the point is do you really think
that we're in a place where you can
freeze that process
now it's like it's god-given right this
is a religious perspective
the scientific perspective is you know
we don't know what of the things that we
believe today we will come to discover
are false tomorrow right but we
understand that that is the pattern
anybody who's studied the history of
science knows that and so yes the idea
that departing from heterodoxy is
evidence of something having gone awry
or somebody overstepping
uh the bounds or something is is
nonsense on its face
now to steal man say fouchy's and the
so-called expert's position here
this does come down to is this an
individual versus a population level
analysis
um because the you know the assessment
that say joe was doing
and that we have largely been doing when
we have talked about these things
here are is this the right decision for
you
is this safe for individuals and the
epidemiological question
is a different kind of analysis the what
what amount of protection does a
population need so that we can safely go
back to normal
and you know what does safe mean and
what is your tolerance for risk and all
of these things need to be wrapped up
into that but it
that is a different kind of analysis
well it is a wholly different kind of
analysis but my claim
is that we are actually not in a
position where anybody gets to wave that
at you and the reason they don't get to
wave that at you is because
they have botched their side of a
contract right yeah and
believe me i i'm i'm always in this
weird position where i have to explain
what my own values would mean if we were
if we were navigating this the way i
think we should be navigating this
we would be having a thoroughly open
discussion in which heterodoxy was
absolutely welcome
and people were able to level whatever
challenges and be protected in so doing
and so we would have a
really good understanding of what the
risks of these vaccines are
what the risks from covid are what the
uncertainties about both
are and then once we had done that
analysis once people had hashed out the
question
of how do we compare
the risks that come from covid with the
risks that come from
vaccines based on unknown technologies
accelerated through this process
once we had done that i do feel like
society has
the right to coerce people to take their
share of the risk to shut down
a pandemic that threatens us all but we
aren't remotely in that world and i
don't want to be told by
any of these people who are busy
participating and obscuring those risks
that i or my children or people
who know better have to take these risks
because that's simply
part of you know our our duty to society
society has fallen down on its side
of this equation and of course the irony
of ironies
is that fauci is the one telling us what
our duty to society is
right because fauci played a role in
uh restarting gain of function research
which it is ever clear or may have
played a decisive role in creating the
pandemic so
you know frankly you know this i'm sure
that that was an honest mistake on his
part
but the fact is some people like fauci
used to believe gain of function
research was safe enough that we could
engage in it and not put the world at
risk of a major pandemic it's becoming
clear
that that wasn't the case right whether
or not this pandemic is the result
of a laboratory escape it is clear that
things escape laboratories routinely and
gain a function research is perfectly
capable of creating a nightmare virus
and so did it happen here we have yet to
find out
but wow is fouchy not in a position to
wag his finger at the rest of us
yeah um also there's the mask fiasco
where he
uh you know lied about whether or not
masks were valuable
um and then later acknowledged that's
what he had done so
he's not he's not in a position to do it
but if i can just reset the discussion
just slightly i want to point out
that there is a hierarchy of categories
and that all of these discussions should
recognize
that we are being asked to move from one
category to another so actually
zach could you put up the uh risk
categories for the living that i sent
you
so i've not seen this um my claim
actually can you give me one of your
copies
sure in fact that is your copy i printed
it for you
um so my claim
is that there are four large categories
that you could be in
the first one is you haven't had covid
or a vaccine that's the category
you and i are in and that one carries no
risk in and of itself
and an unknown ongoing susceptibility to
covet risk
that is to say you are the risk is zero
of not having a vaccine and not having
coveted and the risk of getting covet is
unknown so this is very unclear to me i
i think i know what you mean
but obviously if you haven't if you're
not protected from kovid covet as we
have said many many times
is a dangerous disease oh yes there's no
risk i mean there's not no risk
no well i think this would be come clear
as well okay go through it
the point is you're not having a risk
from either covid
or the vaccine if you haven't had either
you do have a risk of getting covid
which will be destructive
and it is a very dangerous disease but
you don't have any risk going forward
from your status because you're
basically
you haven't been affected by either yet
second category
is you have had the vaccine but you have
not had
covet right now presumably that has a
small
short-term risk although i don't think
we have a good
sense of how small that short-term risk
is and there are certainly
a tremendous number of anecdote even
just among the people that we know who
have gotten
the vaccine of all kinds of pathologies
that have shown up
and the long-term risk in category two
that is to say you have had the vaccine
but you have not had covid
is entirely unknown we don't know what
the long-term risk of these
vaccines is the third category is you've
had covid
but no vaccine there is substantial
short-term risk from having had covered
tissue damage as we have covered
many times and the long-term risk from
having had covet
is unknown but likely substantial that
is to say tissue damage has an ongoing
cost
and then there is category four where
you've had both and i've had to divide
this into two because the order in which
you've had
covid and the vaccine probably makes a
big difference
if you had covid first
then there might even be a benefit to
those who have had what's called
long-haul covid
right there is some evidence that
there's some anecdotal stories of people
getting recovering from long-haul coping
after getting a vaccine right
which i i should say in passing i think
implies that long-haul covet is an
autoimmune disorder
right because if if you have
autoimmunity your immune system is now
attacking your tissues having cleared
covid but it still thinks there's
something there
and it's attacking you and then you
flood the system with spike protein
generated by the vaccine that may occupy
the cells that are otherwise attacking
your tissue
and give you relief
okay um and then
category the category four you've had
both but you had the vaccine
first then you will have
greatly reduced coveted risk that is to
say
we believe from the data we have seen
that covet is less severe if you get it
having had
the vaccine um and that means you're
less likely to get it and it's less
likely to be severe if you do get it
right um and uh that
uh yeah it's less likely to be severe so
you probably have a reduced long-term
risk though we don't know that for sure
either yep
okay my basic point here so i will say i
just i think it's
i i think it's guaranteed that that
screenshot is going to be taken
out of context of the conversation and
the idea that having had covert
vaccine is no risk is nothing that you
actually believe
and that is um i i i wish you hadn't
written that on this piece of paper
because
that's not what you mean yeah i
absolutely do not as we have said many
times and as i have said to joe rogan
i believe on his program um the fact
that
covet is less deadly than we once
thought is
misleading people it's a very dangerous
disease on the basis
of tissue damage and it's robbing people
of
uh years of life in all probability if
everything we understand about
physiology and tissue repair is true
then the significant damage it does is
very harmful and you definitely want to
avoid covid
that said we are in a situation
where without the ability to know what
the long-term consequences are
you do have to ask a question about for
whom
is it worth taking the risk of the
vaccine and that's the thing that
that joe was addressing so um before we
go to the economist thing which you
you've just sprung on me at the very
last minute i have not seen yet so
um can we just show the cdc table since
that is something that is easy to
interpret and it's not um
interactive so zach you can show my
screen
which both brett and i are familiar with
already this is a
chart at the cdc updated february 18th
of this year
risk for covert 19 infection
hospitalization and death by age group
so they are they've split um age groups
into
um several of different
um different spans which is weird all
right zero to four years
old five to 17 years old 18 to 29 30 to
39 40 to 49
50 to 64. why they expand the
the number of years as we're getting
older and as the risk is getting higher
i don't understand like this
this is a strange strange table um
and then there's three categories cases
risk of risk of getting it in each of
those age groups
uh risk of hospitalization each of those
age groups and risk of death in
each of those age groups and as we've
said many many times focusing only on
death is not the right way to think
about the true risk of this
disease and for the purposes of this
table
they have used the 5 to 17 year old
category which is too broad
but the 5 to 17 year old category as the
reference group so that's sort of that's
that's default that's um that's one
and what you can see uh for those um
listening only and not watching is that
interestingly
cases um increase
uh the older you get above 17 years old
um in until you get to 65 to 84 year
olds and then it's down again
um so i don't know what that's about um
well it could be that the cohort is
small i don't know how
what the methodology was well it's
ratios it's not it's not absolute
numbers
um but but the two other the two other
metrics that they're using here are
hospitalizations and deaths
which follow exactly what we all know
everyone who hasn't been under a log for
the last 14 months
knows which is that the older you get
the greater your risk of hospitalization
and the greater your risk of death with
for instance in
just for hospitalizations 18 to 29 year
olds are six times at risk as five to 17
year olds
uh the next age group is 10 times then
15 then 25
40 65 95 times the risk for 85 plus
year old people and it's for death it's
8 700 times the risk
but before you say something here um
what is also interesting is that the
very young
zero to four year olds actually have a
higher risk of hospitalization and death
from kovid only twice but then do the
five to 17 year olds
okay but i have to say this chart has me
jumping out of my skin
i cannot think of a justification for
having put it together this way
it is absolutely misleading and in a
direction that we are now being scolded
with
and i believe it uh you know i i cannot
establish
it could just be ineptitude that caused
this but the idea
of these broad categories in a case
where you have
not even a linear relationship in which
the hazard goes up with time
but an exponential relationship the idea
of grouping
5 to 17 year olds making them the
reference category and then deriving an
8700 times uh
risk from that reference category that's
basically using the fact
in in this is a scary table but in fact
what it says is that the number is very
very tiny in that 5
to 17-year group and the fact is
5-17 years is a weird jump to have made
so
the i don't i don't know what's
misleading back when we were in graduate
school
yeah i uh did a joke survey you may or
may not recall we were in the field
and um my joke survey in costa rica
costa rica um what i did was i did a
survey to see what the density of
non-avian dinosaurs
was per hectare in a study area
and the way i did my study was i had
categories i would count the number of
non-avian dinosaurs
and i had a category if a hectare had
zero to five
i ranked it as 2.5 etc
right and then it turned out
that there were um an average of 2.5
dinosaurs per hectare
that's that's hilarious but
i don't see how like this this
table chart i don't even know what to
call it um this this table
yes lumps 5 to 17 year old people and
we know that we can get greater
granularity than that and the 5 to 10
year olds are at significantly lower
risk than the 10 to 15 year olds for
instance
but um but there's nothing that goes
counter to those numbers here we've just
in
in this case we've just got a collapse
of two categories that are very very
similar a sophisticated person can
figure out what this chart does and
doesn't mean and what it does mean is
that they've effectively done surgery
with an
axe right those large categories don't
have to be there it doesn't add clarity
and in fact you can see if you go to the
economist as an alternative way of
viewing this kind of information
so i'm not vouching for this because i
have not seen it you just
literally sent it to me so scroll up
zack you can show it honey okay that
chart
okay this chart gives you enough
granularity to see
what the uh the risks are right so
people are some people are just
listening what what are we looking at
what we are looking at
is scroll back out scroll back out
estimated covid19 risk if diagnosed in
the united states
and what we have is a curve it's
not perfectly smooth but we have a curve
and you can see risks are extremely low
you can switch between males and females
right so at 21 go to 21 you have about a
1
risk of hospitalization so this is the
exact number that joe rogan was talking
about
for men and it's way low it's even lower
and then you can move by age and you
also can
add uh medical conditions
as you want if interestingly i think i
added asthma just to see how it worked
and the numbers drop i've also heard
that
so that paradox seems this seems cool it
does not allow us um you know this this
has hospitalizations and deaths and it
doesn't
um say how likely you are to get the
thing in the first place right right
which is what the cdc graph table did
show
right but that cdc table creates
i believe a false impression on the base
of making giant categories for no reason
what my point here is that the
granularity of this
allows you to see how steeply your risks
go up and so
if we're going to wag our fingers at joe
rogan we need to understand that what he
said
requires us to take the condition of a
healthy 21 year old
right to give them an unknown risk from
an from a
unproven technology at that age not only
are they taking
a risk of an unproven technology but
their lives are going to be longer and
so the time
in which something can go wrong is that
much greater as we've discussed here on
dark horse
multiple times and so the point is
if all joe said was that if he was
advising a person at 21
whether or not to take the vaccine if
they were healthy and they weren't going
to take stupid risks
he would advise against it and whether
or not that is the right advice
it is certainly fair for a person or
that person's parent i mean i guess a 21
year old is old enough to decide for
themselves but
that person has to be able to judge what
is the risk that i'm going to do my
self-harm with a vaccine
that i would not suffer if i uh
if i stayed away from the vaccine and so
um that is a reasonable question for us
to ask and again
if some uh panel
that was completely immune from perverse
incentives
and well positioned to see all of the
data
and to look at the patterns was to say
actually we don't know what your
long-term risk is but here are the
reasons we think it's low here are the
risks we think you suffer
you know of both getting covet and if
you get covered what the consequences
are
and here's why this is uh either better
for you
or if it's somewhat worse for you it is
a manageable level of worse and the
advantage that comes to society of
nobody being downstream of you who gets
the disease which mind you
isn't even the case it's not like these
vaccines are perfectly effective at
keeping people
from getting and passing on kovid though
they do appear somewhat effective
so it is a reasonable question to ask
of course it is um it is you know
as you just alluded to it is constantly
a struggle to get the conversation to
toggle explicitly between
individual level decisions and what is
best for society
and um you know broadly speaking
the people on the political right tend
to focus on
individual level rights and the people
on the political left tend to focus on
population level
level rights and um you know we have
been arguing as people who
have long been on the left that of
course we need to be doing both
that we have responsibilities to each
other having gotten
rights from society we have
responsibilities in return
and we also exist as individuals and
um what what the scientific method is
very good at and what you and i are very
good at is assessing
um in this case individual
level risks and the population level
analysis
is tougher and i have yet to see
a careful a careful explanation of what
is going on
to make the recommendations what they
are as opposed to simply let's
let's bludgeon the populace with the
sense that if they don't do this there's
something wrong with them
and um they simply must there are plenty
of us out here
who would like the information and are
not interested in simply taking it on
someone's authority especially someone
who has reliably demonstrated that their
authority is not particularly reliable
well but i think i think my point goes
one step beyond that which
is what we can see of the analysis so
far
tells us that nobody has the information
to balance these concerns right if they
have it it's private we haven't heard it
right well that's that's my point that i
you know i want i i want to have access
to that information
right it would be great to have access
to that information but knowing that we
don't
right knowing that what we have is the
pretense of vaccines that are safe
um when there is at least a large
unknown risk of a long-term hazard and
that that is not being discussed
we are forced to default into actually
protecting our personal well-being
if we haven't been given the information
to say actually why
why is it that i as an individual i'm
taking some risk i'm doing it
because collectively we need me to do it
but if i can't calibrate
the value and can't calibrate the risk
to myself
then i'm justified and in fact i would
say we've got two
two liberal things against each other on
the one hand
we've got the i think
justifiable focus on collective
well-being and having to balance it with
individual well-being
but we also have the precautionary
principle and the fact is we are
effectively being shamed out of applying
the precautionary principle
to our own well-being in order uh to
make this all work
out and at the same time actually zach
would you put up the uh the thumbnail
for
um crystal ball uh
from the hill so this is just one more
piece of information
in the stream but crystal ball had a
very good piece this week
on bill gates and his
insistence that patent protections be
maintained that effectively
pharmaceutical company patent
protections be maintained
in order to keep the flow of resources
going
even though that surely means fewer
people are going to end up vaccinated
and in fact
her accusation is that bill is lying
that he claims there are no
facilities that could be brought into
creating
vaccine if the patents were relaxed so
there's no benefit to doing it
and in fact that is um absolutely false
there are apparently
so what we've got on the one hand is
business as usual taking place in pharma
land
you know we have public financing of the
research that creates these things
and then we have the privatization of
the profits and we don't have a
footing as you might get during a war
where
factories are brought into the national
interest and are making weapons or
something like that what we have is the
pharmaceutical industry
continuing to practice its uh its
business as as usual
in spite of the fact that it will cost
lives if these vaccines are the
lifesavers that
are being claimed so we are being told
we have to take risks that cannot be
calibrated
when others are not showing that this is
you know that all hands on deck moment
and that they are doing the same with
their business profits it just doesn't
add up
you